quand arnaud à vis de ces avis c'est
pour la bonne cause celle d'amnesty
international
comment
il convient ce qu'il aime adam en tête
à nous
il est son idole de toujours
m
mais c'est une première à d'amour vient
chanter une chanson d'arnaud un
personnage arnaud sorte d'anti star un
peu décalé quand je suis sur une scène
j'oublie où je suis tu parce que je joue
pour des gens des deux tout dans la vie
chouette
baudis avait l'hiver
les filles du bord de mer une chanson
qu'il reprend dans tous ses concerts un
instant privilégié quand avec adamo il
interprète sa propre version là
là mais je la connais par coeur la
sienne aussi un seigneur je connais sa
façon de chanter maintenant je l'écouté
plusieurs fois s'il donges
je me suis pris à sa version à lui et
j'en étais
tout autre timbre de voix pour une
chanson d'arnaud celle de stephan eicher
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime et que je
respecte beaucoup et que j'ai beaucoup
piqué voilà beaucoup d idées j'ai piqué
le chinois baic
avec sa voix brisée son grand coeur
arnaud a quelque chose de ces grands qui
nous viennent des bords de la mer du
nord
car c'est ma mère
qui lui a toujours eu